it will be nick goody after
154 career appearances making his first
major league start will be his 14th game
you see the era where it is right now
he's missed
a little bit of time and so for nick
goody he's pitched better i think than
the numbers have indicated 10 strikeouts
for him
so far this season that's out number two
and that'll bring up lauriano
goody ready and he comes home and the
pitch is grounded to third backhanded by
connor polefa
his throw is true it's a one two three
twelve pitch inning
for nick goody and we go to the bottom
of the first
and it's debut season kype a fellow
209 out of atwater california excuse me
high school in atwater california
the merced california native dalton
jeffries
who has dominated the minor league
system so one out one on no score for
solac hitting 268
two homers 20 rbis right-handed hitter
here's the o2 delivery and a breaking
ball is swung out of miss a good slider
over the outside corner
the first big league strikeout for
dalton jeffries
and he shook to it ken because he did
shake
before he threw the first base and then
came back with the
an excellent slider and did not waste
any pitches
so bottom of the first two on two out
well odor homer late in the ball game
last night there's a swing by rookie and
a blast to the right field corner that's
got a chance
that ball is history a three-run jimmy
jack for rugnet o'dore
and the rangers striker early it's
three-nothing texas in the first
well perhaps rude dora has found that
stroke we just showed you
the home run from last night that was
his fourth well
here comes his fifth against the rookie
and it almost looked like he knew
it was gone there is a change up didn't
fade very much
and the rookie reaction that couldn't
tell if he's like oh i hooked it maybe
it's foul
or he knew it was gone and here's ronald
guzman
kuzma on the big left-handed battery the
279
two homers and five runs batted in
oh he hits this ball a ton deep out to
right
dawn a bomb from guzman
and it's a five run rangers first he
looks like a completely different hitter
right now and watch him tattoo this ball
another pitch that was
supposed to be away that had some cut in
it what a shot but he hit canvas out
there that's how
deep he hit that one the very top of the
canvas he pretty much
cleared it bottom third of the open
order machine
heim and kemp here comes the 1-1 and
that's a breaking ball slash the other
way toward the left field corner going
back onto solac it's over his head
at the base of the wall and in play and
that'll be extra bases for machine as he
stands in
at second with a double well he got a
hold of that one against benjamin and
just stayed on it and threw it
and he surprised solace getting it over
his head
using left field little slide piece
just kind of dancing in the middle not
doing much he's in scoring position
right away for jonah heim jonas swings
at the first pitch bangs it up the
middle for a hit
machine to third being sent home by el
puedrique the throw cut off from tavares
and the a's get on the board they trail
five to one like he's a guy who's got a
really good feel
for how he wants to attack a pitcher per
the game situation
so he knew right there look i got a guy
out there we need to get him across
badly three infielders to the right of
second here for the switch hitting
leote tavares who swings from the left
side two-two
fastball strike three on the outside
corner and then some
and one two three for weems and we go to
the top of the fifth heading still 5-1
texas he had the rbi
single in the third let's hit hard
into left field and that's a base hit
jonah heim is two for two
and jonah is two for two today and five
hits now the big leagues
in 16 at bats benjamin deals and pinder
takes strike three call on the inside
corner of fastball
and that's it for the a's in the fifth
no runs they hit one left after four and
a half it's still five one rangers
benjamin's been outstanding goody was
perfect
as the opener three up three down
benjamin now working in his
fifth inning so he brings in jonathan
hernandez now
benjamin responsible for the base runner
but a fine job this afternoon
the five ribbies for matt last night
tying his career high
third time he's done it now here's a 3-2
the runner goes swung on in hit down the
right field line for a base hit in the
corner
la stella's around second going to third
the ball is played back by eli white
listel is around third maybe a play at
the plate the throw and the slide and
safe at the plate he got his hand right
on top of the plate
ahead of the tag by jeff mathis and now
the a's trail five to two
and olsen's at second base but did we
get a tag
oh so close yes one out left
nobody aboard 1-1 this one
popped up back of second base and
andrews will take care of it and just
like that
game one in the books and the rangers
take the opener
five to two